juli 2008 ein spezialflug aus libyen
landeten genf
an bord hannibal gaddafi sohn des
mächtigen diktators seine gattin
leibwächter und dienstpersonal hannibal
gilt das pervers brutal und eitel
er frönt dem alkohol und führt einen
ausschweifenden lebensstil
seine gattin elin ist model und stammt
aus dem libanon
die beiden kommen nach genf weil aline
hier ihr zweites kind auf die welt
bringen möchte die schweiz war für sie
beispielhaft das perfekte land das paar
und sein gefolge logieren im hotel
president einen der teuersten der welt
sie belegen zehn zimmer und eine suite
im dritten stock
[Musik]
doch in diesen luxuriösen räumen spielen
sich unschöne szenen ab die ehe von
hannibal und seiner schönen frau ist
alles andere als harmonisch
die zimmermädchen sehen und hören als
hannibal trinkt zu viel und erzürnte
damit seine gattin
dieser lässt ihre wut an ihrem
dienstmädchen allem aus jeden tag
misshandelt sie die junge frau bringt
sie zum weinen dann eines tages hält
allem die misshandlungen nicht mehr aus
die überwachungskameras hier erstmals zu
sehen sind zeugen des dramas hier zeigen
sie als hausmädchen allem und kamal
hannibals mann für alles ihr schicksal
schweißt sie zusammen
[Musik]
samstag siebter juli 2008 allem verlässt
verängstigt die suite von aline
laut ihrer aussage hat ihre herrin sie
mit einem hölzernen kleiderbügel
geschlagen
[Musik]
am nächsten tag wird allem erneut
geschlagen und bittet das zimmermädchen
um hilfe sie sagt aline wolle sie nach
ihrer rückkehr in libyen töten
[Musik]
das hotelpersonal alarmiert die polizei
am 12 juli 2008 sprechen polizeibeamte
im hotel vor
als sie die verletzungen von allem und
kamal sehen nehmen sie die beiden mit es
ist 17 uhr 55
allem und kamal wagen das unglaubliche
sie zeigen das paar an das sich für
unantastbar hält was noch keiner ans die
beiden verwöhnten schützlinge von
diktator gaddafi lösen einer der größten
krisen aus welche die schweiz je erlebt
hat das verfahren nimmt seinen lauf
falls die beiden diplomatische immunität
geniessen wird die polizei wegschauen
andernfalls werden sie zur rechenschaft
gezogen repräsentierte genf am 14 juli
im élyseepalast
mein generalsekretär rief mich an und
sagte mir es liege eine anklage und ein
verhaftung beschluss gegen die beiden
wurde
ich fragte ob ihre immunität geprüft
worden sei und er sagte bern habe grünes
licht gegeben
in seiner mitteilung bestätigt dass
außen der parlament dass hannibal
gaddafi keinen diplomatenstatus genieße
doch bern ist sich der politischen
risiken bewusst und bittet genf diskret
vorzugehen
[Musik]
dumont der confédération sfs wir haben
beim bund die verhaftung beantragt und
diese hat uns grünes licht gegeben
warum hätten wir in diesem fall eine
ausnahme machen sollen
wenn man eine person wird die promoter
so ist das tragen der schweiz wenn man
den dazu bereit dass die person neckar
stroh verfolgt habe und wenn man das
daran die welt gemacht hat dann muss man
sagen alles interessant was derzeit
rohstoffe folge kundus für mich dass
ghani option ein anruf ins hotel hätte
genügt und sie wären diskret entwischt
in paris oder london wurde ihnen diese
sonderbehandlung gewährt
doch hierzulande ist das gesetz für alle
gleich in diesem punkt sind sich genf
und bern einig die genfer polizei weiß
von hannibals unrühmliche vergangenheit
in rom war er in eine schlägerei
verwickelt in paris raste er mit 140
kilometern pro stunde auf der falschen
straßenseite über die champs élysées
außerdem hatte er seine schwangere frau
geschlagen und in paris mit einer
pistole herumgefuchtelt
ohne zu zögern beschließt die genfer
polizei ihn zu verhaften
die überwachungskameras filmen wie der
sohn des libyschen diktators am 15 juli
2008 festgenommen wird
eineinhalb stunden lang versucht die
polizei mit der libyschen delegation zu
verhandeln
sie soll hannibal überzeugen freiwillig
auf den polizeiposten zu kommen
12 uhr 20 die verhandlungen kommen nicht
voran
da gibt der einsatzleiter grünes licht
20 polizeibeamte stürmen in den dritten
stock des hotels doch hannibals
leibwächter versperren den zugang zu
seiner suite die polizei überwältigt sie
dabei wird ein polizeibeamter gebissen
und ein leibwächter am kopf verletzt
12 uhr 25 ein sicherheitsbeamter des
hotels öffnet die drei türen von
hannibal suite die beamten überwältigen
ihn
er leistet keinen widerstand die polizei
dringt darauf ins zimmer von aline ein
und nimmt sie vor den augen ihres
dreijährigen sohnes fest
12 uhr 35 hannibal wird abgeführt
die operation hat zehn minuten gedauert
um kein aufsehen zu erregen führt die
polizei hannibal durch eine hintertür ab
und setzt ihn in einen mercedes mit
verdunkelten fensterscheiben die genfer
polizei hat gaddafi junior festgenommen
aber er wird wie jeder normalsterbliche
in die nächste polizeiwache gebracht
dort da verrauchen ein beamter bietet
ihm ein bier an
doch er lehnt ab da es alkoholfrei ist
nervös behauptet hannibal die
hausangestellten hätten sich selbst
verletzt
er verbringt die nacht in der zelle
aline die im achten monat schwanger ist
wird mit der ambulanz ins krankenhaus
gefahren wo sie unter ärztliche und
polizeilicher kontrolle die nacht
verbringt für die genfer polizei läuft
alles korrekt sie handelt nach gesetz
noch weiß sie nicht wozu ihr häftling
fähig ist
dann long cientanni ball seinen ersten
angriff er behauptet die polizei habe
ihm einen plastiksack über den kopf
gestülpt ich weise seine beschuldigung
vollumfänglich zurück die genfer polizei
benutzt nie plastiksäcke wenn sie
jemanden verhaftet und ganz sicher nicht
wenn es sich um gaddafi junior handel
zwei tage nach der verhaftung nachdem
der hoteldirektor bestätigt hatte dass
im zimmer nichts beschädigt worden sei
verwüsteten hannibals leute die suite
sie wollten den eindruck erweckten seine
verhaftung sei auch nicht tolerierbare
weise erfolgt eine der vielen
inszenierungen in dieser affäre die
narbe von hannibals hausangestellten
kanal ist hingegen real
an die wahl hat mich in sein privates
gefängnis gebracht wo ich täglich
geschlagen wurde
mein ganzer körper weist spuren davon
auf er hat mich mit einem messer
verletzt das sind abdrücke der
handschellen
viele spuren zeigen dass sie uns wie
sklaven behandelt hat
berlin hat mich schwer misshandelt sie
hat mich geschlagen
an den haaren gerissen mit heißem wasser
verbrüht in die brüste gekniffen mit
einem kleiderbügel geschlagen
sie schlug mich jeden tag ich war ihre
gefangenen
mein einziger ausweg war die polizei zu
alarmieren
hannibals katyn wird im krankenhaus
vernommen sie streitet alles ab
die drohungen die schläge die
verletzungen auf die frage ob sie drogen
nehme sagt sie nein ich bin schwanger
am 17 juli 2008 zwei tage nach der
verhaftung stehen sich beschuldigte und
kläger gegenüber
in diesem raum wird das paar gaddafi dem
richter vorgeführt und hinter
verspiegelten scheiben sind ihre beiden
terrorisierten angestellten auch während
der verhandlung wurden sie beleidigt sie
haben mir erzählt dass hannibal sie als
schweine hunde und [ __ ] bezeichnet
habe die richter habe das nicht bemerkt
weil es nicht übersetzt wurde
[Musik]
berlin verneinte alles und verstand die
welt nicht mehr
hannibal war aggressiv herablassend und
verachten
sie sahen sich als könige die über das
leben ihrer angestellten verfügen
konnten
das paar kommt gegen kaution frei 500000
franken ein geschenk für die
multimilliardäre ihre anwälte beteuern
dass keinerlei fluchtgefahr bestehe
unser klient wird auf keinen fall
fliegen er hat keinen anlass die schweiz
zu verlassen ihr will die justiz helfen
einige stunden später fliegt anibal mit
seiner familie und seinem gefolge nach
tripolis und aisha gaddafi die mächtige
tochter des libyschen herrschers tritt
mit einer warnung auf
auge um auge zahn um zahn
unrecht hat derjenige der begonnen hat
tripolis fünfzehnter juli 2008 ein
wolkenloser sommermorgen noch scheinen
die beziehungen zwischen der schweiz und
libyen ungetrübt da stört ein hoher
libyscher beamter die idylle in der
schweizer botschaft durch eine
ungeheuerliche nachricht hannibal wurde
in genf verhaftet
[Musik]
er sagte mir sehr offen
wir wissen dass sich hannibal nicht
immer korrekt verhält
doch das ist für uns zweitrangig am
wichtigsten ist für uns und dafür müssen
sie sorgen
die medien dürfen nicht darüber
berichten da sagte ich ich kenne keine
details aber was ich sicher nicht
verhindern kann ist dass die medien
davon wind bekommen
die libysche diktatur kennt keine
pressefreiheit entsprechend eisig
reagiert der libysche gesprächspartner
alarmiert greift botschafter von muralt
zum telefon
in genf sagt man ihm nichts
untersuchungs geheimnis in bern sind
alle in den ferien ein funktionär
versuchten diplomaten zu beruhigen und
sagt ich bete für sie
das war wie hiroshima wir wussten wir
würden gigantische probleme bekommen das
war klar
in cross selling rachid hamdani mit
seiner tessiner gemahlin lebt bereitet
sich der geschäftsmann auf seiner reise
nach tripolis vor
ich hörte im radio die geschichte mit
hannibal und dass er verhaftet worden
war
eine frau fragte mich willst du wirklich
nach libyen fliegen
ich sagte warum denn nicht und bestieg
das flugzeug als rachid hamdani
libyschen boden betritt wird er bereits
von gaddafis leuten gesucht sie sind in
seinem büro eingedrungen
gegen 11 uhr rief mich meine sekretärin
an und sagte die polizei kam
versiegelte das büro stellte wasser und
strom ab und sagte zu uns wir dürfen
hier nicht mehr arbeiten
das sei ein illegales büro aber rachid
hamdani hat keine angst
er glaubt sich geschützt durch seine
schweizerisch tunesische doppelbürger
schafft sein partner ist nicole stucki
ihre geschäfte laufen gut
die beiden hatten schon aufträge vom
libyschen regime und ein vertrauter von
gaddafi ist sogar aktionär ihre
gesellschaft
[Musik]
doch nun gilt rachid hamdani als persona
non grata die libysche polizei ist
hinter ihm her am abend kreuzen drei
bewaffnete männer bei ihm auf ohne ihm
zu erklären warum nehmen sie ihn auf den
polizeiposten mit dort saßen vier männer
auf dem boden tranken tee und riefen
endlich haben wir einen schweizer
direktor ich verstand nicht was mit mir
passiert
zur gleichen zeit knöpft sich die
polizei einen anderen schweizer vor
dieser hat einen typisch schweizerischen
namen max göldi
er ist länderchef der abb in libyen
max göldi bleibt ruhig er hatte ein
reines gewissen
er rief die botschaft an und sagte die
polizei ist bei mir was soll ich tun
dort hieß es dass sind staatsvertreter
sie dürfen keinen widerstand leisten
max goldt die dusche zieht eine krawatte
an und folgt den polizeibeamten
brutal und ohne erklärungen werden
rachid hamdani und max göldi in eines
der finstersten gefängnisse von gaddafi
gebracht der tod wäre mir lieber gewesen
als diese situation jede minute empfand
ich als qual war schrecklich wie ein
tier käfig es gab keine fenster nur eine
öffnung in der decke durch die luft
herein kamen in der zelle waren wir 18
männer und ist ab nur zwölf betten
es waren die schlimmsten momente meines
lebens gaddafis leute haben es auch auf
einen dritten mann abgesehen einen
deutsch-schweizerischen handwerker der
in diesem moment nach europa zurück
fliegen will
während wochen wird er zu einem streng
gehüteten geheimnis die drähte schweizer
geisel
er wurde verfolgt und fühlte sich
bedroht
doch es gelang ihm ein taxi zu nehmen
und in die botschaft zu flüchten
bei uns ist es uns gelang ihm ein visum
zu beschaffen und ihnen auszufliegen
inzwischen ist klar kein schweizer ist
in libyen mehr sicher ganze familien
suchen schutz in der botschaft
alle glaubten die libyer seien hinter
jedem schweizer jetzt gaddafis anhänger
schrien vor der botschaft nieder mit der
schweiz
der sohn unseres führers worte
gedemütigt und ich fragte mich was mache
ich nun der botschafter wird unter druck
gesetzt und tag und nacht bedrängt eines
nachts wird er gegen mitternacht
vorgeladen man legt ihm ein beweisstück
vor das zeigen soll wie schlecht
hannibal in genf behandelt worden sei
gibt es auch ein mann kommt auf mich zu
zeigt mir ein weißes t shirt mit
blutflecken und sagt stellen sie sich
vor herr botschafter das ist hannibals t
shirt so wurde er im genfer gefängnis
behandelt
ich gestehe ihnen ich musste leer
schlucken
dann sagte ich in unseren gefängnissen
behandelt man die leute nicht so
nach zehn tagen werden max göldi und
rachid hamdani aus dem gefängnis
entlassen
aber sie müssen in libyen bleiben ihre
geschäfte bleiben geschlossen ihre pässe
konfisziert bern schickt eine delegation
nach tripolis
noch glaubt die schweiz es gehe um
verhandlungen zwischen zwei
zivilisierten staaten
wir meinten wir könnten die krise mit
einer erklärung des bedauerns lösen
libyen lässt sich nicht erweichen
da beschließt die schweiz die geiseln zu
befreien
aussenministerin michelin calmy rey
beauftragt spezialkräfte einen
entsprechenden plan auszuarbeiten
da die verhandlungen herzten wollten wir
die liebe über listen hätten wir das
nicht versucht würde man es uns
vorwerfen
der schweizer geheimdienst teilt seine
pläne dem botschafter mit der die
geiseln informiert ich informierte die
beiden auf dem dach der botschaft damit
uns niemand hören konnte weil wir ja
nicht wussten ob die botschaft verwanzt
war
der plan ist einfach die beiden sollen
das schwimmbad des telekom riesen
ericsson besuchen laut plan sollten die
beiden ins eriksson gebäude gehen
dort wurde ein auto mit einem libyschen
fahrer auf sie warten und sie übergab
dem es nach algerien fahren
doch im letzten moment ich weiß nicht
weshalb wurde es abgeblasen
ein anderer plan wird geschmiedet
die beiden werden angewiesen jetskis zu
mieten und aufs meer hinaus zu fahren wo
sie von schweizer spezialeinheiten
evakuiert werden sollen
doch auch dieses vorhaben scheitert im
letzten moment
[Musik]
daniel von muralt hat
meinungsverschiedenheiten mit bern und
wird in die schweiz zurück gerufen
zu diesem zeitpunkt setzen max und
rachid bereits ein jahr in libyen fest
die sache wurde von anfang an schlecht
angegangen
leider verstanden die schweizer behörden
nicht wie gaddafi und dessen familie
tickten hannibal sein halbbruder mutter
7 seine schwester und sein vater waren
schlecht auf die schweiz zu sprechen
saif al islam war flexibler aber seine
meinung zählt er leider nicht
hannibal sagte mir etwas dass mich sehr
beunruhigt wenn sie diese geschichte so
regeln dass sie die beiden schweizer
ausfliegen jage ich das flugzeug in die
luft
hannibal will nur eines sich rächen
und er weiss sein vater steht hinter ihm
hans rudolf merz ist überzeugt
vermitteln zu können als er im august
2009 in tripolis landet der schweizer
bundespräsident ist bereit mit ministern
zu verhandeln obwohl in libyen allein
muammar al-gaddafi entscheidet märz
macht konzessionen die schweiz werde
sich entschuldigen und das verhalten der
genfer polizei untersuchen
sogar die namen der polizisten die
hannibal verhaftet haben plant märz
offenbar preiszugeben zuversichtlich
reist märz nach bern zurück
die schweiz hat einen neuen
geschäftsträger für libyen ernannte
stefano lazzarotto
die geiseln haben ihre pässe zurück
bekommen die freilassung scheint nur
noch eine frage der zeit
doch dann publiziert eine zeitung die
polizeibilder von hannibal der künftige
bundesrat didier burkhalter erklärt
öffentlich schweizer spezialkräfte
sollten die geiseln zurückholen
und noch schlimmer aus libyscher sicht
mischling karriere verweigert dem
populärsten der gaddafi-söhne die
einreise seif al-islam verlangte ein
visum wir beschlossen es ihm zu
verweigern da wir sein gesuch unter den
umständen als provokation empfanden es
war eine sehr schwierige zeit
denn die geiseln waren in gefahr jeder
schritt den wir unternahmen konnte sich
gegen sie richten die libyschen behörden
lassen sich nichts anmerken und bitten
die schweizer zur angeblich letzten
medizinischen kontrolle vor der ausreise
ins krankenhaus
alles schien normal
vor allem hatte man uns versprochen wir
könnten in drei tagen ausreisen
was sie uns sagten schien zu stimmen ein
arzt empfängt sie er bittet den
schweizer diplomaten am eingang zu
warten und nimmt max und rachid mit sie
führten uns in ein zimmer wo man uns den
blutdruck messen wollte meine war sie
hoch 220 der arzt ordnet ein
elektrokardiogramm und eine
röntgenaufnahme an die geiseln werden
von einem raum in den anderen geführt
plötzlich stößt man sie durch eine
geheimtür
max versuchte noch lazzarotto anzurufen
um ihn zu informieren
aber man ließ sie nicht telefonieren
dann stießen sie uns in ein auto das
davonbrauste
ja sagt er
[Musik]
vor der notaufnahme wird der schweizer
diplomat immer nervöser er kann die
beiden geiseln nicht mehr erreichen
die beiden männer die er beschützen
sollte wurden gekidnappt
ich wurde wütend als ich merkte was
passiert war
dann musste ich ihren familien erklären
dass die beiden verschwunden sein und
wir nicht wussten wo sie waren der
diplomat sucht max und rachid in ganz
tripolis und in allen gefängnissen
geplagt von schuldgefühlen und der angst
um die beiden geiseln
verliert er in wenigen wochen zehn kilo
während der ganzen zeit ihrer
gefangenschaft wussten wir nicht ob sie
noch am leben waren
ich denke das gehörte zur strategie
libyens man wollte uns damit unter druck
setzen
max und rachid werden an einem geheimen
ort gefangen gehalten
sieben wochen lang isoliert und von der
welt abgeschnitten
sie hätten uns töten oder irgendwohin
schicken können wo uns niemand mehr
gefunden hätte unsere regierung konnte
nichts mehr tun um uns aus dieser
situation zu befreien
die zellen der beiden schweizer sind
nebeneinander aber sie haben keinen
kontakt und können nur mutmaßen oder
andere noch lebt anhand von spuren in
der dusche oder schulen vor der türe
[Musik]
dieses gefühl der isolierung spüre ich
heute noch es war für mich als gäbe es
mich nicht mehr sagt der libysche
vize-außenminister erklärt im schweizer
fernsehen die beiden seien weder
entführt worden noch würden sie als
geiseln festgehalten
wir haben sie in sicherheit gebracht
wegen die publikationen in ihren medien
gewissen äußerungen eines
parlamentariers und aus anderen gründen
die beiden schweizer sind keine geiseln
[Musik]
die einzige chance das kräfteverhältnis
zu ändern und das leben der geiseln zu
retten und sie zu befreien war die eu
einzubeziehen und die krise zu
europäisieren
das aussenministerium sucht eine
möglichkeit um den gaddafi-clan unter
druck zu setzen dann die idee die
schengen visa liste wenn die schweiz den
libyern die visa verweigert dürfen sie
ganz europa den schengen raum nicht mehr
betreten
am vierten november 2009 ist es soweit
die ganze zeit der bis zu acht romane
und das ist der punkt
sie hat und durch 14 c max ich habe mir
natürlich durch eine vorwahl krieg vor
der wiese könne verhindern dass die wir
überhaupt noch europa können reisen und
das hat er jetzt kommt bewegung in die
sache
fünf tage nach der visa verweigerung
werden die gefangenen schweizer
plötzlich in ein taxi gesetzt dass sie
zur botschaft zurück fährt
[Musik]
waren außer uns vor freude wir hatten
nichts davon gewusst
plötzlich klopfte an der tür der
botschaft der chauffeur rief rashid max
er hat vor freude geweint
auch lazzarotto war dort alle weinten
es war der einzige freudenausbruch in
der ganzen geschichte
es war einer der bewegendsten momente
meines lebens sie wohlbehalten wieder zu
sehen
wunderbar ab da leben die beiden
schweizer eingeschlossen in der
botschaft langeweile wechselt sich ab
mit angst das lachen auf den weihnachts
bildern 2009 täuscht gaddafi hat
inzwischen den spieß wieder umgedreht
er will die beiden vor gericht bringen
er verlangt dass sie die botschaft
verlassen
doch sie weigern sich weil gaddafis clan
nicht mehr nach europa reisen darf hat
der diktator inzwischen allen europäern
die einreise nach libyen untersagt das
kommt schlecht an in der eu
michelin calmy rey wird in brüssel
heftig kritisiert auch weil sie das visa
verbot ohne vorwarnung eingeführt hatte
sie sagten zu mir sie hätten uns
wenigstens warnen können so geht das
nicht
ich antwortete hätte ich es angekündigt
hättet ihr mich unter druck gesetzt es
nicht zu tun wenn wir die situation
retten wollt setzt libyen unter druck
damit sie unsere geiseln ausreisen
lassen
das schicksal der beiden geiseln zählt
wenig angesichts der interessen gewisser
länder in libyen hätte sich die eu
gegenüber der schweiz nicht solidarisch
zeigen sollen
jetzt ist die schweiz also eu-mitglied
fantastisch eine gute nachricht
wir haben keine probleme mit libyen die
schweiz schon
wir lieben die schweiz aber sie darf
nicht europa in geiselhaft nehmen
die europäer haben uns nicht geholfen
weil sie uns lieben sondern weil wir
miteinander an allianz bilden weil wir
das schengen abkommen unterzeichnet
haben
der entscheid der schweiz brachte die eu
in schwierigkeiten gegenüber libyen das
vergeltungsmaßnahmen beschlossen hatte
das ermöglichte uns die verhandlungen zu
beschleunigen um das problem zu lösen
hinterher muss man michelin calmy rey zu
diesem mutigen entscheid gratulieren
auch wenn er zu einigen schwierigen
momenten zwischen uns und der schweiz
geführt hatte neue verhandlungen
beginnen jetzt unter europäischer
leitung mischling calmy rey muss das
visa verbot zurückziehen
die libysche seite ihrerseits zieht ihr
visa verbot für eu bürger zurück aber
die sofortige freilassung der geiseln
verweigert sie ich habe sie zum weinen
gebracht
aber sie weinte nicht wegen mir sie war
am ende ihrer kräfte
der druck war massiv
und sie war nicht bereit nachzugeben
außer die beiden geiseln würden
gleichzeitig freigelassen
aber libyen will ich denn nicht ein
gaddafi stellt ein ultimatum
bern habe wenige stunden um die geiseln
auszuliefern
er hat unterschiedliches vor mit den
beiden rashid soll freikommen
aber max muss ins gefängnis
am 21 februar 2010 um stellt die
libysche armee die schweizer botschaft
stefano lazzarotto versucht zeit zu
gewinnen
je mehr zeit vergeht desto stärker wurde
der druck
schließlich drohten sie mir wegen meiner
mangelnden bereitschaft würden sie in
die botschaft eindringen und den
schweizer max göldi mitnehmen dass sie
oft pocher wird aus dir ins gebäude kann
man dass unsere leute sind
das geistliche vater sind das auch noch
alles zerstört wird dass alle fans
auffällige dokument könnte für die lied
das ich für uns ist das im eigentlichen
das passiert in diesem moment bittet die
österreichische botschafterin ihre
kollegen in libyen um hilfe diese
begeben sich in die schweizer botschaft
um eine gewaltsame erstürmung zu
verhindern
[Musik]
das war ein starkes zeichen der
solidarität in einem schwierigen moment
den wir wussten nicht wie es weitergehen
sollte hatte mir geraten keinen
widerstand zu leisten
bern sagt die botschaft müsse sich für
einen angriff wappnen
der diplomat befiehlt also alle
offiziellen dokumente zu verbrennen
mitten in der nacht ruft libyen die
rebellischen botschafter zusammen und
wirft ihnen vor ihr beschützt einen
verurteilten verbrecher die botschaft
wollen sich nicht mit dem libyschen
regime anlegen und fordern von den
geiseln sich zu ergeben
diese haben keine andere wahl es war
klar dass libyen die botschaft stürmen
würde um uns festzunehmen
wir fragten die schweizer behörden was
sollen wir tun müssen wir uns ergeben
ihre antwort das müsst ihr entscheiden
die schweiz hatte immer die gleiche
haltung sie überließ uns die
entscheidung und blieb stets neutral
max traf eine entscheidung doch sie fiel
ihm schwer
eher straff mit seiner familie und
seinen anderen ausweg
es war ein dramatischer moment ich habe
keine worte dafür
er bewies bemerkenswerten mut
eine surreale szene stefano lazzarotto
in seinem blauen auto beschleunigt und
verfolgt die polizei
er will max göldi nicht aus den augen
verlieren
[Applaus]
rashid hingegen ist fast frei
als letzte erniedrigung muss er ein
interview geben das ihm zuvor diktiert
worden ist
rachid hamdani sagt die schweizer
regierung habe ihn in eine schwierige
situation gebracht in dem sie ihn gegen
seinen willen in ihrer botschaft
festgehalten haben
in einem interview dankt er den libyern
für ihre fürsorge die sie ihm während
seines langen aufenthalts zukommen
ließen
dann ist der weg frei für die rückreise
in die schweiz
maxim geben ist wieder im gefängnis
hannibal will seine große menschlichkeit
demonstrieren und besucht ihn begleitet
von medienvertretern
heute hat ihre mutter geburtstag ja ihr
besuch ehrt mich sehr
ich habe meine familie schon lange nicht
mehr gesehen
es tut mir sehr leid was ihnen und ihrer
familie in genf passiert ist hannibal
erlaubt max goldie seine mutter
anzurufen
max göldi weinte als er seine mutter zum
geburtstag gratulierte hannibal sah wie
ihm die tränen herunter liefen und sagte
wie einfach ist es doch jemanden
einzusperren
hannibal hat seine rache aber die
geschichte ist noch nicht zu ende
für mich war es sehr schwierig und auch
demütigend die schwarze liste vor den
libyen aufzuheben
das war ein großes risiko meine kollegen
aus dem bundesrat sacken zu recht dass
wir so keine garantie hätten die beiden
geiseln freizubekommen
mischling karriere versucht einen
letzten ausweg sie kontaktiert cécilia
attias die ex frau des französischen
premierministers sarkozy als sie noch
französische präsidentengattin war hatte
sie dazu beigetragen dass gaddafi die
bulgarischen krankenschwestern freiließ
michelin calmy rey hat alles versucht
es ist nicht einfach bürger des eigenen
landes in geiselhaft zu wissen
sie war sehr besorgt und ließ nichts
unversucht
da sagte ich zu ihr ich schaue was ich
tun kann
cécilia attias reist nach tripolis und
trifft sich mit dem premierminister
ein treffen mit diktator gaddafi
persönlich kommt nicht zustande
aber sie telefoniert lange mit ihm ging
es nur um die macht etwas anderes gab es
nicht für ihn
er musste immer seine macht beweisen
doch dann sah ich eine möglichkeit
er trug auf dem revers seines jacketts
eine afrika karte er wollte ein tor für
afrika sein
ich sagte zu ihm niemand nimmt sie ernst
wenn sie geiseln in ihrer gewalt haben
wenn sie also wirklich ein tor für
afrika sein verhalten sie sich ehrenhaft
libyen mach dir darauf einen vorschlag
wenn sie durchsetzen könne dass die
genfer polizisten bestraft würden könne
sie libyen mit den geiseln verlassen
cécilia attias kontaktiert mischling
calmy rey die ihrerseits den genfer
stadtrats präsidenten anruft
[Musik]
sie rief mich an und sagte sie habe eine
gesamte in tripolis
wenn ich hier versichern können dass die
polizeibeamten bestraft würden kämen die
geiseln frei ich sagte es stehe außer
frage die beamten zu bestrafen
sie sei er einmal im gleichen kanton in
der regierung gewesen und wisse deshalb
dass das nicht gehe
sie erwiderte wir sollten einfach
funktionären nehmen die bald pensioniert
werden und so tun als würden sie
bestraft
ich versprach er ich würde das in der
regierung besprechen aber ich sei
ziemlich sicher dass die antwort negativ
sei man kann ja nicht einfach
unschuldigen oder polizeibeamten die nur
ihre pflicht getan hatten den schwarzen
peter zuschieben
wir mussten den rechtsstaat respektieren
das war eine ständige forderung der
liebe und jedes mal haben wir in genf
angefragt und jedes mal haben sie
abgelehnt
und dann hat auch die eidgenossenschaft
nein gesagt auge um auge zahn um zahn
wir mussten sie beim wort nehmen während
der verhandlungen haben die liebe ja
immer wieder gefordert dass diese
polizeibeamten bestraft werden
mehr noch dass sie entlassen oder
frühzeitig pensioniert werden
so in der art
die genfer polizei beamten die hannibal
festgenommen haben fühlten sich seit
jenem verhängnisvollen tag bedroht sie
befürchten sie könnten von gaddafis
leuten auf genfer boten entführt werden
zwei jahre lang gehen sie jeden abend
auf einem anderen weg nach hause die
libyschen sicherheitsleute hatten den
ruf effizient und brutal zu sein
die genfer polizei war deshalb sehr
besorgt was wenn der gaddafi-clan
selbstjustiz üben und sich an den
polizeibeamten rächen würde diese
möglichkeit müssen wir ernst nehmen
im august 2009 hätte hans rudolf merz in
libyen beinahe die namen der drei
polizeibeamten die hannibal verhaftet
hatten bekanntgegeben
im letzten moment wurde die vereinbarung
jedoch geändert
wir konnten verhindern dass in der vom
bundesratspräsidenten unterzeichneten
vereinbarung die namen der
polizeibeamten aufgeführt waren
aber wir mussten einem schiedsgericht
zustimmen
zehnter mai 2010 die vereinbarung ist
unterzeichnet
sie enthält im wesentlichen die
bedingungen die märz ausgehandelt hatte
zudem soll die schweiz 1,5 millionen
franken an ein karitatives werk
überweisen
das vom gaddafi-clan ausgesucht worden
ist doch noch muss max göldi freikommen
michelin calmy-rey und der spanische
aussenminister begeben sich nach
tripolis
eine riskante reise
dort erleben sie zwei turbulente tage
zuerst müssen sie eine erklärung abgeben
dass die einhaltung der vereinbarung
garantiert sei dann folgt eine
pressekonferenz
gaddafi lässt die delegation mehr als 24
stunden warten
endlich werden alle ins zelt des
diktators gerufen
[Musik]
es war irgendwie so real
wir waren mitten in tripolis in eine
kaserne die mit stacheldraht eingezäunt
worden
dort gab es eine riesige wiese und
darauf stand ein zelt sie waren etwa 60
bis 80 personen
man sagte uns das sei die versammlung
der vergebung nicht zurück ich sagte zu
mir jetzt können wir endlich max göldi
mitnehmen also bleiben müsse gaddafi
fragte mich woher kommen sie ich sagte
aus genf er sagte auch so dann begann er
die schweiz zu beschimpfen und sagte die
westschweiz sollte zu frankreich gehören
ich antwortete keinesfalls und erklärte
ihm die historischen zusammenhänge da
erhob sich müsse berlusconi und sagte
hören sie ich lasse nicht zu dass die
schweiz kritisiert wird ich wurde im
krieg von der schweiz aufgenommen das
ist ein friedliches land
da sagt über darf ich nichts mehr gegen
die schweiz
die bundesrätin und der spanische
minister gehen voller hoffnung in ihr
hotel zurück dort müssen sie erneut
warten
am nachmittag erhielten wir vom
premierminister die schlechte nachricht
dass herr goll die nicht mit uns
ausreisen können
da riskierte ich alles und drohte die
komödie ist zu ende
wir kommen nie mehr nach libyen und das
wird gewaltige konsequenzen haben
es war eine der härtesten verhandlungen
die ich je erlebt hatte die drohung des
spanischen aussenministers zeigt wirkung
mischling karriere kann sich endlich
entspannen
der libysche premierminister persönlich
lässt max göldi frei doch dieser darf
nicht mit der minister zurück reisen
er muss allein zurück fliegen
[Musik]
die schickte ihm eine sms um sicher zu
sein dass er im flugzeug sass er
antwortete sofort ich warte auf den
abflug anscheinend hat das flugzeug
verspätung
wir warteten ein paar minuten
[Musik]
max göldis steigt in tunis in den
bundesrats flieger um
am 13 juni 2010 nach 22 monaten ist er
endlich wieder in seine heimat
ich bin müde aber sehr glücklich dass
ich endlich wieder in die schweiz bin
ich bin opfer eines konfliktes geworden
der nichts mit mir zu tun hat es ist ein
sehr emotionaler moment für mich und ich
bitte sie um verständnis
[Musik]